listen people that have female audiences
make millions and trillions of dollars
podcasting I have an audience mainly of
men because I'm talking sense but the
problem with men is that they don't you
know I'm not recapping the Real
Housewives or whatever else you ladies
are into it's amazing to get its a gay
it's like it was like all your gonna be
gay and then you have to be around a lot
of women it's like wait what I'm kidding
I have a very much respect for the
ladies out there and I love you and I
want more of you to listen and I want
you to buy the [ __ ] products okay
that's what I really want to happen I
have a male audience it's not my fault
it's the way it shook out but the women
who do listen to me are special women
they are bosses they are gangsters they
run businesses they are prostitutes they
are sex slaves they are drug addicts
they give themselves abortions they are
queuing on they're trying to steal
people's children they think we're
kidnapped by sex cults they are they
have cuing on tattooed on their [ __ ]
these are special ladies they think they
were abducted and [ __ ] by George Soros
the women that connect with my material
have been to prison not Jail prison
they've done a stretch or two they've
killed their parents or their children
or both the women that connect to my
show are special women they've thought
about hiring someone to kill their
husband they've thought about it they've
never done it but they've thought about
it they sit in that suburban hell
they've created for themselves and they
hear my voice they hear it as the voice
of freedom and they think what would I
have to do to just get this stupid log
out of my life and go do something that
really speaks to my soul and to them I'm
saying go to magic spoon com slash Tim
Dylan to grab a variety pack and try
today and be sure to use our promo code
Tim Dylan my name T IMD I
because I want to make lots of money and
I need the women to do it cuz men are
stupid apparently and don't [ __ ] buy
anything and just binge free content
because they think they've all got to
figured out you haven't got to figured
out your nothing out there men
I need women I want an audience of 5000
[ __ ] they just buy my [ __ ] this show
might turn around and be straight-up
catered to the [ __ ] hoes I might come
on this show and be like I'm your hoe
that's where we're going if you start
buying magic spoon cereal I'll do the
show and [ __ ] drag and I'll talk
about whatever horseshit you want me to
talk about The Bachelor avvocato toast
cleaning out your [ __ ]
whatever you want I'm in I'll do it I
don't know if the blabber about the CIA
to these broke [ __ ] all the time
who cares these retards will go in their
backyard and shoot at their tree these
[ __ ] militiamen or wherever the
[ __ ] Lissie we'll get him out of here
we'll dump him on the side of the
[ __ ] Road I want [ __ ] that spend
money Instagram influencers basic
[ __ ] that spend it's you who this ad
is for you are the ones that need to
stay attractive and you know why because
the world is unfair and beauty and roads
and all of that [ __ ] that I'll talk more
about if you buy the magic spoon cereal
and if I find out you're not buying it I
will have no choice but to keep doing
what I've kind of been doing what you
steer the content to more of a male
domain more of a kind of thinking based
show it's a joke it's funny because it's
not true men are [ __ ] women are
[ __ ]
everyone's dude I forgot this isn't is
this an ad still they're gonna believe
these people I don't care it's good
cereal by this year I'm not I'm not
kidding anymore about this I'm gonna
come to your house and I'm gonna kill
your family if you don't buy the cereal
I swear to god I'll select one of you in
random I'll come to your [ __ ] house
and I'll blow my brains out in front of
you
and every day for the rest of your life
you'll see the gun going into my fat
mouth as I blow my head off in front of
you if you do not buy his [ __ ] cereal
okay buy the cereal magic spoon comp
slash Tim Dylan and God help you if you
buy this [ __ ] cereal and you don't
use the promo Tim deal if you buy the
cereal and you do not use the promo code
I swear to God I will drive LA homeless
Corona patients to your [ __ ] house
and I will let them in your backdoor and
they will cough on all of your [ __ ]
while you're out cereal
I want to get the ads going that's my
point here patreon is great but we got
to get the ads gone you know you know
why all the big podcast in LA don't have
patreon because they have and I'll
always do a patreon because I always
want to do content then I like the idea
of patrons five bucks see in four hours
is [ __ ] it's good it's real deal [ __ ]
you're not getting [ __ ] over I've sold
a lot of bad products in my life
subprime mortgages copier machines it
didn't work and I'll do it again but the
point is that the patreon is actually a
good deal but a lot of these big
podcasts in LA they don't need that
because everybody buys the [ __ ] so just
buy this [ __ ] please I'm not gonna get
less funny I know you know what I mean
I'm not gonna get I think some of you
think I'm gonna get less funny when I
when I when I like have a home when I
can afford a house he was gonna happen
if I can't afford out I'm gonna kill you
I'm gonna kill all of you I'll find the
way to kill all of you I don't know how
I'm gonna do it I'll figure out a
[ __ ] way I'll kill every last one of
ya kill my whole audience